alexis poulain cofondateur du monde
moderne
bonsoir merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur arte france alors on l'a vu en
contrôles renforcés aux frontières en
france quand que pensez vous de cette
mesure prononcée par jean castex
aujourd'hui c'est une mesure de bon sens
évidemment les aéroports étaient des
vraies passoires aco vide qui arrive
encore une fois un peu trop tard et qui
pose question parce que en france on a
choisi d'avoir c'est ce pays
prioritaires desquels on va tester les
personnes qui cale de ces pays là alors
qu'en allemagne et la liste est encore
environ 230 pays donc déjà une question
pourquoi la france choisit seulement
c'est ce pays quand l'allemagne en
choisissant 30 est ce que la france en
fait pas assez ce que l'allemagne en
fait trop est ce que l'europe là
n'aurait pas son mot à dire justement
parce qu'une fois qu'on arrive en france
grâce à schengen
on peut aller où on veut en europe donc
si les allemands sont au courant de ça
peut-être qu'ils vont appeler jean
castex pour lui demander de revoir cette
liste est de dire qu' il faudrait
peut-être tester tout le monde
systématiquement qui arrive et puis
l'autre question qui se pose bien
entendu c'est les tests au départ à
savoir qu'est ce qui prouve que le
laboratoire est un vrai laboratoire que
le test a été fait est que la personne
qui arrive avec l'attestation d'un test
négatif à bien un test négatif
là encore peu de garanties la 14ème
c'est une bonne mesure bien entendu
difficile à appliquer puisque il ya le
temps du test aussi quels tests vont
être mis en place
combien de temps pour dépister la
personne malade et le traçage de la
personne malade est ce qu'on va aller
rappeler des gens qui sont arrivés à
leur dire finalement vous savez il va
falloir se mettre tout ça est très floue
mais ça va dans le bon sens parce
qu'évidemment on ne peut pas continuer
de faire comme si le virus n'arrivait
pas en france par l'avion il arrive en
france par l'avion par la voiture par
toutes sortes de moyens de locomotion et
donc les aéroports sont prioritaires
parce que aujourd'hui l'épidémie
eh bien elle continue d'augmenter
partout dans le monde même si en europe
on a mis des mesures et on a pu contenir
pendant un temps cette épidémie
du gros navires us une mesure qui
devrait être opérationnel au plus tard
le 1er août très serré a dit réalisable
pour le gouvernement
j'espère faire une annonce de cette
importance là sanitaires et ne pas la
réaliser ce serait catastrophique pour
le gouvernement donc si ces mesures sont
prises c'est que les moyens sont mis en
place parallèlement alors il ya le
problème logistique bien sûr des tests
de la rapidité de ces tests de la façon
de deux pistes et dans tous les
aéroports mais clairement et c'est pour
ça d'ailleurs que je pense le 1er août
est la date clé durant les jours qui
viennent tout ça doit s'organiser
rapidement
encore une fois c'est une mesure de bon
sens qui aurait dû voir le jour bien
avant
compte tenu de ce que disaient les
infectiologues et les différents
médecins et qu'il fallait absolument
faire des contrôles à l'arrivée aux
aéroports on se rappelle tous de ces
images à l'époque où monsieur darmanin
était à bercy où il était avec les
douaniers pour ouvrir les sacs
simplement des voyageurs qui arrivaient
en france le virus ne se cachait pas
dans les sacs vous là vous en avez parlé
tout à l'heure avec l'allemagne qui
compte plus de 130 pays sur la liste
rouge
le premier ministre lui a simplement
évoqué la catalogne dans son allocution
quelles sont les zones à éviter
absolument et est ce qu'il faut ce
concorder justement avec l'allemagne
comme vous l'avez dit tout à l'heure je
crois que ce serait normal compte tenu
de schengen que tous les pays européens
se mettent d'accord sur la liste des
pays parce que si on n'a pas la même
liste de pays à pays bien on va arriver
finalement à faire rentrer sur le
territoire européen par un pays ou un
autre des pays qui ne seraient pas
autorisées dans un autre pays mais une
fois que vous avez par l'avion en france
vous prenez le train et vous pourrez
aller en allemagne
et là il faudra sans doute peut-être un
nouveau contrôle aux frontières mais
c'est beaucoup plus compliqué que à
l'aéroport donc moi je ne comprends pas
cette union européenne qui ne veut pas
s'organiser qui refuse finalement de
s'adapter à sa réalité si elle choisit
d'ouvrir les frontières avec schengen ça
veut dire que la frontière eh bien elle
se déplace à l'extérieur des pays
partenaires européens et que donc tous
doivent avoir les mêmes règles d'accueil
et d'ouverture des territoires c'est dû
à quoi selon vous un manque de
discussion en manque de solidarité juste
un problème économique
je crois que c'est dû beaucoup à la
géopolitique de chaque pays qui n'a pas
les mêmes alliés dans les différentes
régions du globe
c'est dû aussi à la rapidité dont les
pouvoirs publics peuvent mettre en place
en france on a ce conseil de défense qui
prend du temps c'est à dire qu'il faut
attendre le conseil de défense pour que
des mesures comme celle ci soit annoncée
en allemagne ça va beaucoup plus vite au
danemark où ailleurs aussi donc là la
façon de décider fait qu'en france on
perd du temps et puis après le manque de
concertation
on a pu le voir lors du récent sommet
européen c'est d'abord chacun pour soi
et puis ensuite l'europe pour tous mais
il va falloir compte tenu de cette crise
qui est là pour durer le christ
sanitaire du coc u19 bien il va falloir
s'organiser autrement et peut-être
revoir les règles et en l'occurrence ça
me semblerait normal que tous les pays
européens se mettent d'accord sur une
liste de pays au delà de l'espace
schengen et intra schengen qui sont à
risque potentiellement risme hautement à
risque on peut avoir une différente
différents une graduation en fait du
danger
merci beaucoup alexis poulain d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes co fondateur du monde moderne